have you heard one inkling about jameis
winston
you know no this is this to me is like
that that's a weird one right now where
i look at
i haven't heard jack diddley about
jameis winston
i haven't heard jack diddley about
jedevian clowney you know either one i
haven't heard one thing not one rumor
not one inkling nothing
clowney's got to have a physical right
and nobody's touching clown without a
physical for winston that's not the
issue no i know and it just makes me
wonder where is jameis winston gonna end
up i really don't know you know as i've
told you i know there was a lot of
coaches in free agency and some guys i
saw at the combine and things like that
that are all very intrigued by james
winston oh i'd love to get my hands on
him and do that you know but is he the
guy that's the prototypical backup you
know that's what i think is probably
gonna scare teams too they're gonna go
damn you know backup we you know we want
a talented guy but damn we want a guy we
can trust too and do all that so he's
probably a little scary from that
standpoint too and we don't know what
kind of money he's asking for on the
open market but right now he might not
have a a whole lot of choices he might
have to lower his price tag
and is he willing to be a backup some
teams want a guy
who says i'm just here to support the
starter i'll hold the clipboard i'll
push the starter in practice i'll help
him get prepared
is that what he wants or does he want to
go somewhere where he would be competing
and does that fit with what a team is
looking for in a back-up quarterback
look i think the saints make the most
sense for him i hear that look at him i
hear you for teddy yeah for what it did
for teddy bridgewater
and you have an opportunity to play if
drew brees gets injured again and he's
41 maybe he gets injured again you work
with sean payton you iron out some of
these rough spots and you've got great
weapons like michael thomas i think
that's where i would want to go i'm not
as big on pittsburgh as a possibility i
don't think ben roethlisberger would
embrace jameis winston franklin the way
that drew brees would i think the saints
make the most sense yeah i i hear you
mike you know and that's a team that has
crossed my mind they got to find some
sort of backup i don't think they want
to just have taysom hill be their backup
backup because then they can't run him
or wear him out certain weeks with their
taysom hill package because you're going
to be worried about oh we're going to
our backup quarterback hurt so yeah that
that uh jameis is very intriguing right
now and i have no feel for where he ends
up
in august of 2019 not all that long ago
peter king spoke with jameis winston
during his training camp tour and
winston said
to peter regarding the possibility of
playing baseball it is one of my dreams
it is something i would definitely look
forward to you have to ask yourself
if he's not happy with the offers he
gets if he's not happy with the role
that he would be playing does he say
screw it i'm going to go the tim tebow
route i'm going to get involved in
professional baseball class a level or
even sub class a work my way up
rediscover baseball and see where it
takes me
that may be the thing that he does and i
know that's always been one of the
questions now he's not at the same skill
level as kyler murray who could throw
away football anytime he wants and go
back to baseball but winston was good
enough that it's always been a question
it was a concern of the buccaneers five
years ago they put a clause in his
contract that would have given them the
ability to go to court and prevent him
from playing baseball anytime anyplace
anywhere
now he can go play baseball and maybe
he'll feel unburdened by football and
the money that football
gives him if he's not getting the kind
of money he's looking for and maybe
baseball is where he ultimately goes man
i mean it just would be such a hard
thing to make happen now i mean it's
just you know that's baseball you know
it's just gosh you just leave it for
a number of years and think you're just
gonna jump back in there and be the
player you were you know plus you know i
know it's not perfect in football but
you know people like me and you they see
a lot of the positives jameis winston
can bring to the table too
so
you know to me
where i i almost look at it to go like
man one of these teams
that's you know really feels like the
49ers would be a team where i would tell
my buddy kyle shanahan go you know
you got nick mullins maybe you keep him
right but bring in a jameis winston if
you can get him for the right price what
would be the wrong thing there see what
he's got see what he's about maybe if
you're not happy with jimmy garoppolo at
the end of 2020 you know he's a guy that
could be have potential to do something
like that you know even a team like
kansas city you know i don't think we
know mahomes is the guy they're a team
that's in the super bowl window you know
you know that would be another team i
might think about it if i'm uh those
type of teams if it's the right price
for a jameis winston
well it reminds me of the last
buccaneers first round pick at
quarterback um josh freeman yeah right
when he was cut the vikings pounced on
him and the argument was hey
you're always looking for a franchise
quarterback right you never know where
you're gonna find one maybe you're gonna
find one in jameis winston 50 109
passing yards chris five one zero nine
eight all-time single season performance
at a quarterback uh i i i think that
there's value in that yeah and i am
stunned that he's not in the
conversation to be the starter anywhere
um and and uh i think he would be a
viable backup and i think that maybe he
takes a step back
whether it's with the 49ers the saints
or somewhere else learns the game from a
different perspective that's right
and he's still young yeah he's still
young he's still got a lot to offer
quarterbacks play deep into their 30s
now and i i think that winston i'd hate
to see him leave football i'd hate to
see him jump into any other sport i
wanted to stay
and uh he's just got to get just like
todd gurley's got to get his brain
around the idea that he's not a
workhorse jameis winston's going to have
to get his brain around the idea that he
was supplanted by tom brady hey there
are better court far far worse options
out there for quarterbacks who will
supplant you from your job and now you
go about phase two of your career yeah
hoping that phase three puts you back
under center on a regular basis no doubt
about it you gotta make the move that's
right for your career here just like we
saw teddy bridgewater do where you go
damn it might not be exactly what i want
but this makes the most sense and puts
me in a position to succeed to where if
i do get a chance to play i can kind of
jump start my career again and have
people view me as a starting quarterback
once again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports